Thor after all this time and now you  come to visit me  why and he come to gloat to mock okey  enough no more illusions now you see me  brother  and she suffer I did not come here to  share our grief instead I offer you the  chance of a far richer sacrament go on I  know you seek vengeance as much as I do  you help me escape Asgard and I will  grant it to you  vengeance and after with this cell  you must be truly desperate to come to  me for help  what makes you think you can trust me I  don't bother did  you should know that when we fought each  other in the past I did so with a  glimmer of hope that my brother was  still in there somewhere that hope no  longer exists to protect you you betray  me and I would kill you  when do we start  you